as you know with this current virus
pandemic people's jobs have changed many
people were asked to work from home some
were furloughed and others saw changes
in their working environment like social
distancing and the introduction of PPE
or the office for national statistics
has compiled this list of data that
looks at deaths covered 19 deaths
relating to occupations among men and
women aged between 20 and 64 across
England and Wales and it's looked at a
total of 4,000 761 deaths to examine the
correlation between being exposed to
kovat 19 and physical proximity and it
found that in two-thirds of those deaths
they occurred in men and particularly
men working in elementary occupations
who had the highest rate of deaths and
elementary jobs can be described as
routine tasks like construction workers
and cleaners and of course you'll know
that many of them are considered key
workers so they would have continued to
go into work during this pandemic and
you can see from this table now that
there's a list of jobs that had seen the
most deaths and this is in relation as I
said to men and you can see that
security guards they're right at the top
with the highest rate of kovat 19 deaths
now when it comes to the social sector
both men and women saw significant
raised numbers of deaths and in the
healthcare sector so that's including
doctors and nurses and people that work
in hospitals like cleaners and porters
hospital porters as a group men had an
elevated rate of death but not women but
when you break that up into separate
roles nursing was the industry which had
significantly higher rates of death and
that's for both men and women while the
office for national statistics didn't
take into consideration ethnicity or
socio economics but it did refer to a
separate source a survey and that looked
at ethnicity and that found that
specific occupations had higher
mortality rates among black and Asian
ethnic groups and for example that was
bus drivers one of the examples there
and of course next week we see further
easing of lockdown measures with the
opening up of the hospitality industry
so things like pubs opening up and so we
can expect these numbers to change if
there is a further update from the Oh
because while healthcare workers are of
course exposed to that Cove in nineteen
risk perhaps on a near daily basis they
do of course wear PPE which isn't the
case for hospitality workers who have
that very close proximity with their
clients and their staff but perhaps
don't don't wear the PPE necessary